NORTH KOREA.
IT WOULD BE A GREAT THING FOR
THE WORLD.
>> 6:00 A.M. FOX AND FRIENDS,
REACTION OF THE NIGHT'S BREAKING
NEWS.
FULL DISCLOSURE, VIKTOR YA HAS
DONE LEGAL WORK FOR ME IN THE
PAST.
I'M PROUD TO BE A FRIEND OF BOTH
OF THEM.
LET'S START WITH YOU, VICTORIA.
>> SINCE LAST DECEMBER, MY
HUSBAND AND I HAVE BEEN SAYING
THERE IS A BRAZEN PLOT TO CLEAR
HILARY CLINTON AND FRAME DONALD
TRUMP IF HE BECAME PRESIDENT,
AND NOW WE ARE SEEING THE PLOT
UNRAVEL.
BRENNAN, CLAPPER AND THE OBAMA
WHITE HOUSE TARGETED PEOPLE ON
DONALD TRUMP'S FOREIGN POLICY
TEAM.
THE PROFESSORS, THEY TRIED TO
GET TWO OF THEM, CARTER PAGE AND
MY CLIENT SAM CLOVE IS, I HOPE
WILL BE WITH US NEXT WEEK.
THEY DIDN'T BITE.
THEN THEY FOUND THE WEAK LINK,
20 SOME-YEAR-OLD GEORGE POP DO
THAT
PAAT
PAPADOPULOS.
IT'S BEEN REPORTED, AND I
STARTED RESEARCHING IT TODAY,
GEORGE PAPADOPULOS TOLD WITH
CLOSE TIES TO THE KREMLIN, THE
RUSSIANS HAVE HILLARY'S E-MAIL.
THAT'S MAY.
THEN SOME BLONDE BUYS HIM DRINKS
AND INTRODUCES HIM TO HER FRIEND
THE AUSTRALIAN AMBASSADOR AND
THE CONVERSATION GOES TO HILARY
CLINTON.
>> HERE SAY IS NOT ADMISSIBLE IN
COURT.
>> THAT DOESN'T MATTER HERE FOR
GOODNESS SAKES.
HE'S JUST TALKING ABOUT --
THERE'S A TERM FOR IT, SEAN.
IT'S CALLED HONEY TRAPPING.
IT'S CLASSIC SPYING TECHNIQUE.
HONEY TRAPPING, USING THE LURE
OF SEX TO GET SOMEONE TO OPEN
UP.
AND THEN --
>> AND BY THE WAY, 25 GRAND --
$25 MILLION FOR THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION.
>> AND TO USE THAT FLIMSY
INFORMATION TO START AN ENTIRE
SURVEILLANCE AND INVESTIGATION
OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN JUST
BOGGLES THE MIND.
>> SEBASTIAN GOR CA?
>> WE NEED TO PUT THIS IN
PERSPECTIVE.
VICTORIA IS RIGHT WHEN IT COMES
TO WHAT WAS DONE OPERATIONALLY.
WHAT IS THIS IN THE MOST CONCISE
TERMS?
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME IN U.S.
HISTORY THAT WE HAVE HAD
INDUSTRIAL SCALE POLITICAL
ESPIONAGE DURING A PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN.
OUR NATION WAS FOUNDED IN A
REJECTION OF THE CAPRICIOUS USE
OF POWER.
THAT'S WHY WE HAD THE
REVOLUTIONARY WAR.
NOW IT'S HAPPENING IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION IN THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY.
WE CREATED THE SYSTEMS TO
DETECT, APPREHEND AND PROSECUTE
SOVIET SPIES, NATZIS AND
TERRORISTS, NOT PEOPLE WHO HAVE
A DIFFERENT POLITICAL
PERSUASION.
THE PRESIDENT WAS RIGHT.
HE WAS SPIED UPON, SURVEILLED.
THEY TRIED TO ENTRAP HIS PEOPLE
AND FRAME HIM.
WE ARE JUST AT THE BEGINNING
OF -- I ASKED CHERYL ATKINSON
TODAY.
SHE SAID WE HAVE UNVEILED LESS
THAN 2% OF THE TRUE CORRUPTION.
>> WE HAVE UNMASKING, RIGGED
INVESTIGATION, SPIES IN THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN, HILLARY WORKING
WITH RUSSIAN LIES AGAINST THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, RUSSIAN LIES
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR, ABUSE TO
THE POINT THEY LIED TO FOUR
JUDGES.
WHERE DOES IT END, VICTORIA?
>> I HOPE -- WE ARE STARTING TO
UNRAVEL AND PEEL BACK THE ONION.
GOD BLESS THE FBI AGENTS THAT
WANT TO COME FORWARD.
WE WERE TOLD THAT EVERYONE IN
THE FBI LOVED JAMES COMEY.